I've had an epiphany I've discovered why
I act crazy I have a vagina just kidding
but I have had people tell me my entire
life that I'm crazy and I'll be the
first to admit okay I can be emotionally
unstable with mood swings cry for little
to no reason and I do suffer from
frequent thoughts of irrationality why
are you a violin well now I know why
birth control yes birth control six
months ago I went off birth control
because I had to switch to a new one but
there was this this period in which I
just wasn't taking it and I was calm and
collected and in control and at the time
I thought like oh and older and just
more mature now
no because when I got on my new birth
control I found myself feeling all the
feelings I realized that it followed
along the timeline of when I was on and
off B C P it makes sense right because
birth control tricks your body into
thinking that it's pregnant so it won't
get pregnant you're basically walking
around like an eternally pregnant woman
what do you mean it's never coming out
right though it is such a relief to know
that it's not me being emotionally
mature it is literally all the hormones
that I am ingesting it helps me keep
perspective when birth control tells me
oh my god so if you are fighting an
excessive amount of emotional imbalance
look at your life and figure that shit
out if you're a guy it's probably not
birth control but it could be your diet
a lack of exercise even a mood disorder
talk to your doctor dude because then
you can have this moment oh is that now
in my last video I didn't add in an
accent and apparently that accident was
really horrible
I knew it but gold star for trying
anyway but someone actually suggested
that I do this next one in a Japanese
accent since this so I was like cool so
I'm gonna do that right now
thank you - oh the Buddha calm for
sponsoring today's episode you can go to
audible.com slash Ana for a free audio
book of your choice
they have over 150,000 title oh wow
crazily I am listening to the end
tamati bike Icicle awesome all because I
have already shown you can get usable or
book of your choice or the world of
Commerce ah that's other blue dot-com ah
shit
ah ah yeah that's that
hey have a good week staffs in Gotham